Some of you may
or may not know, uh
prostitution is legal
in the state of Nevada.
Uh, that would, of course,
cover Reno.
Uh, so right now
we're pulling up to a place
called the Chicken Hole
uh, an establishment
run by our friend, Claire.
You'd think the things that they
do in here would relax somebody
but it has the opposite effect.
- How you doin'?
- Hey, come on in.
- Hi, Claire
- Come here, baby.
- What's going on, sweetie?
- 'Well, I don't...'
You know what, honest to God,
I swear to Christ, I don't know.
I didn't call.
The (bleep) upstairs called.
I called you this time.
Yeah, the shoe's on
the other foot. Check this out.
[indistinct yelling]
Shut up! Shut up!
Hey, Jones, get over here!
Hey, come on, let's go. Come on.
(male #2)
'Let me show you something.'
'Alright, look, look,
let me just tell you.'
- Let me just tell you, okay?
- Okay.
I just finished my lovemakin'.
I just did my-my lovemakin'
over there, alright?
I wanna clean myself off,
I want to take a shower
so I can be respectable.
I walk in here. Look at this.
Look, look, look,
look at all these walls, empty.
No, there's not a sign in here
that says
"Employees must wash hands."
That's state of Nevada law!
(Claire)
'That's because
it's a whorehouse, you ***.'
You still
got to be clean, whores!
But you're loud, okay?
You know what?
How many times you've been here,
Andrew, 25, 26?
And today you're gonna
complain--
Today's the day that
you complain about the damn--
Let me tell you something,
it's been brewing.
It's been brewing 'cause
I'm thinking about myself.
I'm thinking today.
I'm finishin' my lovemakin'.
I got juices all over me.
I got my male juices.
I got the female juices on me.
When you blink, you got juices.
There's,
there's juices everywhere.
But let me tell you something.
So I got to clean
those juices off.
When I walk in here, no one else
is cleaning their juice.
I'm like, "My God!"
"I'm makin' love in juice."
But let me tell you something--
You know, if you wanna wash,
go to a KOA campground
pay-pay a quarter
for a goddamn shower.
Oh, she says, "Thank you."
Like, I get that reference.
Okay, okay, shut the (bleep) up,
bitch!
You want a shower?
Let's get a shower.
- Oh, you wanna go there--
- Take your shower--
- Yeah. There you go--
- All clean now--
- 'Boo!'
- There you go--
[clamoring]
Alright, you know what?
I don't care...
- Ladies, call your congressmen!
- Boo!
(Jones)
'Boo! Boo!'